they are the stuff of nightmares they
dwell in filth and feed on decay but
maggots might also be the next thing
your doctor pulls out of his medicine
bag maggots are the larvae of another
creature with an image problem to fly in
nature flies lay their eggs in rotting
flesh
so the maggot hatchlings won't have to
stray far to find food
this tastes for dead flesh is what makes
maggots taboos but it also makes them
perfect for use in medicine here in
Wichita Kansas at the Weslie Medical
Center's Midwest Center for wound
healing a new patient has come to try
maggot therapy for the very first time
Cyndi Kennedy suffers from diabetes four
months ago she had an abscess taken from
her abdomen that left a gaping wound
conventional procedures are causing her
so much pain that she can't cope but if
the wound is left untreated infection
might spread throughout her body and she
could die the solution to place hundreds
of live maggots into the wound the
secret lies in their eating habits these
maggots eat only dead flesh and leave
healthy tissue alone
dr. Terrence McDonald has been
prescribing maggot therapy for four
years the maggots are a kind of a
clinging device for these worms not only
do they remove the dead tissue which
removes the food source for the bacteria
then their saliva has antibacterial
effects but to Cindy the thought of
maggots feasting on her body doesn't
necessarily sound appetizing you know
they say it really gets the job done so
I'm willing to try anything the two
millimetre long larvae are specially
bred for use at wound care facilities
these maggots are newly hatched and
their family nup the green and black
decaying flesh they might save Cindy
from having it surgically removed before
the day is done she'll have as many as
700 maggots placed in her wound for 48
hours the hungry maggots will feed on
her diseased flesh and when they
finished feasting they'll grow to five
times their original size two days later
Cindy returns to the clinic to see if
the maggots have cleaned out her wound a
lot of these areas are really a lot
cleaner the tissue that I can see and
there is all pink
proof fun life but for Cindy even a
medical miracle is not enough to
overcome her taboo for creepy crawly
creatures yeah
it's Airy especially if you have a fear
of birds I think what it's only doing
their job I mean I can understand that
and I appreciate that
but I'm glad it's over
if maggots can overcome their taboo
reputation
these creatures of death may keep eating
their way to saving lives